the ukrainian president's top security
official has a strong suspicion who's
behind a massive cyber attack on his
country
and he says it could signal a new
physical assault will follow
with a warning to ukrainians to be
afraid and expect the worst the cyber
attack began at about 2 a.m local time
and hit around 70 government websites
the foreign ministry among those
affected
alexi danilov reveals that some defense
and security sections within government
have since been put on an even higher
state of alert in case of further
hostilities
do you think this cyber attack is
a first shot that will that is coming
before an actual physical military
attack
results
do you really believe that there is a
chance that new military action from
russia against ukraine could come as
early as tomorrow
russian snipers pictured training close
to ukraine's eastern border this week
even though president vladimir putin has
denied he's planning a new invasion
he's also previously denied allegations
of cyber attacks
at a key cyber security center in kiev
they're taking no chances
officials helped to respond to the
latest attacks they registered the cyber
is that that happened uh
today and uh they exchanged data and
coordinate with other teams
how to respond to this incident
while in other rooms a training
session's going on to bolster their
defenses for the next one everybody is
doing his work our soldiers
these are
protecting our waters and we here are
protecting ukrainian cyberspace
a reminder that in today's conflict the
front line is everywhere
debra haynes sky news kiev